hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ich wollte ich einfach nur kurz bescheid
sagen dass ich jetzt am samstag und am
sonntag als am 28 29
mai auf der kirchenbank messe in
dortmund sein werde und zwar ist es in
der westfalenhalle ein bisschen jeweils
von morgens bis abends dar
ich bin damit meinem gesamten team und
da gibt es einen stand von mir mit
meiner küche
da werde ich dann live für euch kochen
und backen und es gibt natürlich auch
autogramme und wir werden auch fotos
zusammen machen
ich möchte jetzt nur kurz vielleicht
schon mal vorweg sagen also weil viele
immer da sind die dann eben auch gerne
etwas länger warten als wir werden
natürlich ganz viele autogrammstunden
machen aber ich möchte natürlich auch
ein bisschen was kochen und backen weil
er auch viele dass in dem ich eben auch
in der küche sehen möchte und mir
vielleicht fragen stellen möchten
und das will ich auch mal ganz schön
weil ich dann meine zuschauer auch immer
so ein bisschen kennenlernen kann
bei den autogrammen ist es dann so dass
wir dann immer eigentlich alle dran
nehmen
nun muss sie natürlich auch immer mal
eine pause machen weil ich auch die ella
mit dabei habe und die muss ich
natürlich dann auch stillen und geht
dann eben ab und zu kurz in die pause
bei den letzten messen war es oft so
dass ich zum beispiel auf dem weg zur
toilette oder zur ja auch mal kurz
abgefangen wurde
und ich hab dann eben immer gesagt nie
kommen kommt damit in die
autogrammstunde und ich meine dass auch
eigentlich gar nicht böse wenn ich mich
einfach nicht unfair sein und jemanden
bevorzugen oder benachteiligen und
deswegen denke ich da eben an die dann
eben vorne in der schlange stehen und
kann dann eben außerhalb keine fotos
machen dass ich jetzt nicht weil ich
böse bin sondern einfach nur weil ich
fest sein möchte und eben keinen
benachteiligen möchte was ich euch jetzt
auch noch sagen möchte ich habe jetzt
einen ramadans passion für euch gemacht
und zwar gibt eben dieses jahr vielen
ramadan 30 - von mir
und die besteht nicht nur aus neuen
rezepten sondern ich stelle die auch aus
alten rezepten zusammen und werde die
auf meinem blog jeden tag hochladen und
da könnt ihr euch dann immer so ein
bisschen ideen holen einfach für den tag
was könnte ich kochen und essen ganz
normale rezepte ich hab halt immer eine
vorspeise hauptspeise und manchmal auch
ein dass er mit dabei einfach damit ihr
so ein paar ideen und inspirationen
bekommt und vielleicht könnt ihr mir
jetzt auch noch helfen und zwar bin ich
derzeit noch auf der suche nach einer
torte und zwar möchte ich jetzt auch für
den ramadan mal eine richtig schöne
torte machen und vielleicht habt ihr da
ideen oder wünsche
die ich eben wie heißt die ich beachten
sollte
und vielleicht können damit einfach
bitter was zu senden ich habe jetzt
eventuell an eine bankrotte gedacht oder
ich mache natürlich auch ein motiv torte
also falls ihr da wünsch habt dann
schreibt mir einfach und ich freue mich
jetzt auf alle die am samstag und am
sonntag auf der messe in dortmund dabei
sind es wird auf jeden fall sehr lecker
ihr dürft alle was probieren
unser shop ist natürlich mit dabei und
den murat könnt ihr kennenlernen ist
auch mit dabei der macht dann bestimmt
wieder leckere smoothies für euch
letztes mal hat er sogar irgendwie soup
waffeln gemacht vielleicht macht er die
dieses mal auch wieder
jedenfalls gibt es wirklich den ganzen
tag genug zu essen und zu trinken von
uns auch kotzen muss natürlich alles und
ja wir freuen uns schon sehr darauf und
ich geht's weiter autogramme
vorschreiben denn ich glaube das braucht
man dieses mal weg nicht ich glaube da
jetzt ziemlich voll
also bis zum wochenende bis dann tschüss